انتقادات كثيره لمقطع فيديو تداوله رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في الولايات
المتحده يوافقوا حادثه رش طالبه لاستاذها
برداد الفلفل بعد سحبه لهاتفها المحمول من
يدها في المدرسه وفق ما ذكرت احدى الصحف
الامريكيه فان الطالبه كانت تستخدم الهاتف
للحصول على اجابات من جوجل في اختبار
مدرسي
[موسيقى]
نعم
رشقه محتاجون غاضبون حافله رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اقرا اكرم امام اوغلو بالحجاره
اثناء قيامه بجوله انتخابيه قبل
الانتخابات العامه المقرره نهايه الاسبوع
المقبل واظهر فيديو تحطم من تحطم ونوافذ
الحافله ورشقه بالحجاره اثناء توقفها في
مدينه اردوروم شرقي البلاد
انتشرت صور على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بشكل كبير لقط تعرض لقرصه نحل تسببت في
انتفاخ انفه الامر الذي استدعى نقله الى
المستشفى حيث تداول الرواد الصوره
بتعليقات ساخره عن الواقعه بسبب شكله بعد
تعرضه للقرصه ومن ناحيه اخرى تعاطف البعض
مع القط الذي كان يبدو حزينا فيما اشار
بعض من الذين نشروا الصوره ان القط حاول
اكل من اكل النحله ولكنها باغته وقرستته
ثم هربت
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات